from Forbes GOP LED house Judiciary
Committee opens investigation into
Fannie Willis so I don't know what else
you can ask for I think they should
subpoena her and immediately call it
like you said it looks like they're just
once again being like we are going to be
opening an inquiry into whether we
should inquire about Fanny Willis right
the Republican lead house Judiciary
Committee launched an investigation into
Fulton County Georgia district attorney
Fanny Willis as former president Donald
Trump surrenders himself to authorities
after Willis's office indicted him we
get it
this is Jim Jordan sent a strongly
worded letter to Willis Thursday asking
her to turn over information to the
committee writing her indictment of
trump and his allies involve substantial
Federal interests the letter claims
Wilson's indictment appears to be an
attempt to use state criminal law to
regulate the conduct of federal
officials acting in their official
capacities and raises whether Willis was
coordinated with Federal prosecutors in
the Justice Department regarding her
investigation
they got Trump on federal charges they
they're going to they're going to go
after his lawyers the question is will
the Supreme Court intervene under uh
this argument that Trump was acting in
His official duties as a member of the
executive branch and thus they are
interfering with the federal government
supreme court I imagine is going to say
get out of here with this right they
have to
quash it or what
I don't know it's a strongly worded
letter though so I'm sure everybody's
quivering
Panic ensues as soon as you get some
strongly worded letter I mean I I'm sure
that she's laughing they're probably
passing around the office look at this
look at this guys check out the letter
he sent me a letter leaving a subpoena
they they
they're putting Ben in it for a subpoena
and this is all they can muster up
exactly so he's being arrested
she gets a letter not they don't quite
equate do they I mean
it's frustrating you were talking I
believe earlier today about uh leftist
tactics oh yeah especially within the
riot and that was making me think of
something because my friend Mark
um show partner he's he grew up in that
ilk and he kind of Switched parties over
time and he's like you need to follow
leftist tactics because they are
effective and he's like why the hell
don't Republicans do it and I understand
the conservative mindset well it's not
dignified and that's the problem is the
conservatives are like that's unseemly
meanwhile I don't Democrats are taking
dumps in the streets in San Francisco
Bingo yeah and Republicans are like well
I never and then they're like as the
crackpots take a dump right in the
middle of the street they're like huh we
should arrest that guy and then all of a
sudden the cops jump at your house and
you're like how could you arrest me I've
done nothing as Republicans for you they
should you know honestly I would like it
if every single Republican was arrested
just every single one of them just there
you go and this is like oh maybe now
you'll do some something be harder for
them to do something I think but I think
I know you mean I think there is a lot
of like we shouldn't stoop to their
level we have the moral High Ground on
the other hand it's really hard to
defend the more High Ground when you are
actively losing territory on every yeah
on every other front you are seeding
power so we gotta we have to have a
Reconciliation somewhere no well you've
got to have ground to hold any High
Ground I mean there is no ground if if
they're like okay cool and then they
just push them over and you know you
brought that up very poignantly about
the tactics things of that sort oh I
mean the the leftist tactics are
Advanced conservative right-wing
libertarian Etc just non-existent the
left does stuff like Optics they
understand Optics so they'll get one of
their quote unquote journalists
a video will come out during a cop
beating some guy and they'll be like
help help police brutality and what the
video won't show you is the guy punching
the cop first because the person filming
it will edit that out specifically to
create propaganda and they refer to
themselves in the activist Community not
as journalists but as propagandists then
publicly they'll say they're a
journalist to cover themselves because
what was it vashu said he'll do anything
to win or something like that yeah he's
essentially I mean his his philosophy is
a consequentialist so essentially the
the philosophy boils down to and this is
just a wavetops kind of idea but it
boils down to the results are what
really matters so how you get there
doesn't that's and that's part of why
likes and socialists tend to have that
philosophy a lot because it's how they
deal with the horrors of socialism
they're like well once we get to the
Socialist Utopia the millions and piles
of dead don't matter because then no one
else will die because of whatever the
failings of capitalism that they're you
know because our cult has established
its goal except what happens is once
they use these evil tactics to gain
power they fear someone else using these
tactics to be in power so they maintain
an authority regime which they were once
fighting against they just become the
new authoritan regime and they get mad
when you point it out well because they
know that what they just did yesterday
somebody's going to do to them exactly
because they know the same tactics yep
so um yeah it's a good survival
mechanism I mean the system overall
doesn't work it's low trust people to
get thrown into prison for nothing you
know people use the government to remove
their uh Rivals that are are just in
business or if someone's got a nicer
office than you and you can call the
government be like yo he had you know he
was saying things that are against the
party and the party comes and Picks Them
Up and next thing you know you get the
job now I mean that kind of stuff
happened all the time all over the
Eastern Bloc countries in in when the
Soviet Union was or when it was
communist countries you know when they
were all satellites of the Soviet Union
I don't know man there the reason
there's a Fighting Chance is only
because and I'm not trying to rag on
conservatives but it's only because
dissidents from the left have switched
sides uh art culture and organizational
uh prowess are coming greatly from
people who used to be liberals and left
who are now fed up and working with
conservatives you know with all due
respect Ben Shapiro is still a rather
stodgy dude right yeah he's uh he's a
guy in a suit who's very
um
I don't know preppy I guess you know the
way we would describe it in schools and
I mean that with all due respect like
he's a he's a proper clean-cut
well-mannered man but that's the people
like I don't know Phil you're a rock
star you know what people are into right
I mean some yeah but they're like people
want people want some Freedom they want
some entertainment they want some Edge
they want some punk rock and now that
like what it was it John Johnny Rotten
yeah literally John Biden right wing and
he's like it's the it's the left that
have become insufferable yeah and
and you'll you're starting to see people
in you know in the more
edgy kind of uh genres of music and
stuff like that starting to push back
you see you know like the guys in the
defiant oh that's great the defiant and
uh people were talking about Ronnie
Radke and Tommy vexed who pushes back
against that kind of stuff I've been
pushing back against this kind of stuff
forever
um and it's falling out of favor
um they people don't want to be told how
they have to interact with everyone they
come into contact with they want to know
they want to be like look I'm going to
be polite and I'm gonna try to be nice
and I want to get along with people
but if someone
mispronounces a word or says the wrong
word or says you know says something
that's newly insensitive they don't have
to worry about losing their job they
don't have to worry about the
repercussions they don't have to worry
about being debanked and these are real
things now obviously the people that get
debanked are the people that really push
back against the narrative and stuff but
it's only a certain amount it's only for
so long because as that type of tactic
becomes something that works it happens
more people will do it more and if the
government if they if they see that it
works the government will get into the
business of it social credit scores will
come here they are currently they're in
China right now that is a real threat
they're here now it's just being
controlled by private entities look at
PayPal
right yeah to some degree yeah well it
doesn't matter it's a weird situation
but people are like oh well we're going
to worry about the corporation things
like that well the corporations are
driving this you have PayPal who is
literally doing a social credit score
and taking people's money and then as
far as punk rock well punk rock is
against Authority so who's in Authority
right now right so punk rock is going to
be obviously right wing if left-wing is
an authority left wing liberal
establishment neocons Etc
yeah and it's it's it's not even about
is this a funny thing the left will
immediately say you're claiming that
conservative Christians who are wearing
suit or punk rock no we're saying that
anybody who's truly punk rock who would
say I don't know wasn't it Sid Vicious
who wore a swastika t-shirt yeah that
would not fly with neolibs with the
liberal and left establishment they'd
lose their minds if someone dared do
that punk rock was intending to offend
you
you you like you know and so now these
these all these Hall Monitor types
deeply offended by naughty words they're
the antithesis of punk rock that's not
like the funniest thing it's like I'll
give a shout out to Hassan who is
like it's funny because he is
more like what's the what's the right
word for Ben Shapiro right what's the
word nerd no no no no no no no no no no
no no no I'm talking about a guy who is
clean cut well-mannered button up Hassan
is 10 times more stodgy and buttoned up
than Ben Shapiro is
there is this veneer among the left of
being edgy but they're marching around
chanting amazon.com slogans and Walmart
slogans and being and it's just like we
have this I just absolutely love Hassan
calling in Crossland a conservative that
just right there shows you that it is a
thin veneer of grifting bro any
reasonable person leftists for instance
they call Ian Moon Lord because they
know he's a hippie dippy Crystal Weirdo
And he Rags on Trump all the time who in
their right mind would call this guy
conservative unless you're a grifter
just saying whatever you think you need
to say to earn internet points or your
tribe and you're a cult because if
you're in a cult if anybody Strays from
the cult or tribal narrative they're
gone yeah but in the Olympics even among
woke leftists they call Ian moonlord
right they like these socialists who are
very woke are like yeah Ian's not a
conservative he's a weirdo he's a hippie
weird they call him Moon Lord they laugh
about it and they like sometimes when he
when he yells at Trump and stuff Hassan
is just
I'm gonna say whatever you know if
you're a on B I'm just gonna say
whatever I think people are gonna you
know click on he is like he is as
establishment as establishment can be
he's the dude in high school wearing the
Letterman jacket pushing around the
Nerds Hassan's got some serious audience
capture he is terrified of his chat his
chat runs him like Matt if he says
something if he says something the chat
doesn't like the chat we'll let him know
and and he will quickly evolve the what
he's saying thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time